hey it's Evan and today I'm answering a
question from one of my YouTube viewers
Gary who was curious about how I use
Evernote and wanted to see if it could
work as a potential CRM for his business
so he's a consultant he goes in and he
helps companies with their software and
technology and he wanted to basically
organize every communication with a
client into an easy to find place on
Evernote and how I would go about doing
it so I don't use Evernote too much as a
CRM but here's how I would do it to get
started first thing I do is create a
notebook so you go new notebook I would
put in a client name so let's say I'm
working with Bank of America put that in
Bank of America okay that's going to put
it on the side to make things easy
especially if you have multiple uses for
your Evernote I use it for a lot of
personal and business reasons what I
would do is create a new stack called
clients so I would right click on this
go add the stack create a new stack then
click on it and go rename and put this
as clients then if you click up here you
can see that I have a new stack called
client and then within here I have a
notebook of Bank of America and then
within here I can add new notes that
relate to my client the reason why it's
is important is because you can use it
for a lot of different reasons so you
can see I use it for my book business
notes personal notes my investment
company memories salsa dancing places
the checkout in Toronto have a lot of
different reasons for it and so if
you're using Evernote for a lot of
different reasons you want to organize
your data so it's not crazy out of
control when trying to find something so
that's the reason why you have a stack
called clients and then notebooks for
each client
and then within you have individual
notes so when I'm now in my folder if I
had a meeting with Bank of America
I could go new note and I could put in
something like meeting on November 15th
and I could start typing in the notes
from the meeting so you'll met with
Carrie Smith go to dues and put in all
this stuff you know underneath whatever
you need
and why I like this is I find it helpful
to refer back to you so I use this for
meetings when I'm having mean with
people on my team and we meet once a
month and I'll keep track of what we
said we were going to do and then I can
refer to it the next month when we meet
again to see what's been done and what
still needs to happen on top of that I
can add notes for all the different
types of documents that I want to share
so for example if I sign a new agreement
with Bank of America I would do a new
note I could call it agreement and then
I could go to my regular Explorer and
just drag in the PDF of the signed
agreement so you could drag in pictures
you could drag in agreements PDFs drag
in any files that you need to save and
it's all here and an easy-to-find format
so if I ever need to come back and find
out what was going on and dig deeper
into my notes I could have two choices
one I could click on my Bank of America
notebook and then search just man you
look down and say okay well this was
called my meeting notice of my agreement
and hopefully this will build as you do
a lot of work with your client so you
can manually sort through it here or you
can do a search and you can go at the
top here and you get search and you
search your notes and you could put in
whatever word you're looking for or
agreement or you know you're looking for
Harry Smith you put in Harry Smith and
I'll pull up only the notes that relate
to that client so that's how I would do
it and again I would repeat this for
every new client that I brought on that
I wanted the track you create in your
notebook it's all stored within the
clients stack and it's easy to keep up
to date and you have everything in one
central area and it's it's on your
computer it's on your phone it's on your
iPad any device that's connected to
Evernote you have instant access to all
the information you need and you can
easily edit it as well and when you do
it'll be edited across all your devices
to hopefully that helps a great question
for those of you watching like the video
please give it a thumbs up below and I'd
love to hear what you have to think if
you have a more specific question about
Evernote or another question for your
business leave it below I'd be happy to
do a video response thank you guys and
I'll see you soon